hey guys it's evan i'm really frustrated
tonight i got into fights with five
different entrepreneurs today
challenging day i had tons of meetings
lined up and these are entrepreneurs who
came to me and they have problems with
their business and they're not getting
the results that they want out of their
company
and they're holding themselves back
and i give them great advice i hand it
to them on silver platter it's so
obvious this is what you need to do
to make a bigger impact to grow a bigger
company and they're so resistant to
change they're so locked into their
current mindset so unwilling to do
anything slightly out of the ordinary
and then they argue with me you know you
get defensive say no that's not the way
to do it are you kidding me look at what
your business is doing right now are you
happy with where the company is at right
now
are you having great results
i don't think so
and if you keep doing the same thing if
you don't change if you refuse to let go
of this resistance to change
then you're never going to build a great
company
i know it's hard i know
doing something different is stepping
outside your comfort zone and it's tough
and it's struggling and
and i know i need to have more patience
i feel like i have to to handhold
everybody and and take you through step
by step
and i feel like
i want this for you more than you want
this for you the people i got in two
fights with today i see great things for
their business i see them being able to
help out a ton of people have a huge
impact make a lot of money and their
view is so limited and they're
restricting themselves so much in their
little world
and i see such huge potential and i
don't understand why i think you can be
way better than what you think
why do i have so much belief in what you
can do than yourself
you got to believe in yourself you got
to believe that you can make a
difference in this world have a huge
impact and when somebody comes to you
with an idea to make things better
think about it
you know don't get so defensive
i'm here to help you
my concern is for you i want you to be
better i want you to build the company
of your dreams
anyway i'm going to bed frustrated i
don't know how much i'm going to sleep
tonight
i wanted to make this video to say you
guys are watching
believe in yourself
think big have a huge vision go for it
stop getting sucked into limiting
personal beliefs and when opportunities
come up when people try to help and
support you
listen
try it out see if it makes sense
don't get so defensive and hold back and
hold on to your
small thinking
because you can change the world you can
have a huge impact
i believe in you
and i want you to believe in yourself
so please
believe
if you guys like this
please give it a thumbs up below and i
want to hear you have to think make me
feel better make me know that i'm not
the only one who's thinking big out here
who believes in you
leave a comment let me know what you're
thinking i'd love to hear from you
thanks guys i'll see you soon
you